hey guys today it is a 28 of July I'm
Jess and here's your daily dose of GSP
first up 2k have cut through the rumor
mill and confirmed that mafia 3 is
indeed a thing and we'll be hearing more
about it next month while mafia 2 was
developed by 2k check the games website
revealed that new studio hangar 13 will
be developing the next installment in
the 1940s ayer action game hangar 13 is
headed up by hayden Blackman who worked
at lucasarts for 13 years writing for
various Star Wars games and directing
the force unleashed 2 K have not
revealed platforms for the game but we
did get a promo image featuring four
individuals standing out in the dark
chocolate by car headlights the game's
official reveal will occur during games
come at eight a.m. EDT on august five a
few small details on the first games to
be announced for Nintendo's and ex
console have been dropped maybe although
square enix did backpedal on this one
pretty quickly saying they had nothing
to officially confirm it appeared at
Dragon Quest 10 and Dragon Quest 11
would be among the first and x games the
games were revealed during a live stream
which also announced that the latest
Dragon Quest entry was also coming to
ps4 and Nintendo 3ds when asked to
clarify their development plans for the
NX square said that the releases are
quote under consideration it seems you
won't have to worry about fallout 4
being delayed since the Fez dhruv come
out and said that the game is pretty
much all done in terms of development
Bethesda's Pete Hines tall gamespot that
this does impact on their ability to
implement fan requested features since
it's simply too late he explains the
game is basically done it was by and
large done before we announced it in
terms of the features going in you're
not adding new features in may june july
in the year you're releasing you're
trying to get everything fixed although
it's too late to add anything now Heinz
distress that they have incorporated
much of the feedback from Skyrim and for
three into ultimately making fallout for
a special game let me know down in the
comments if you reckon fallout 4 is
going to be better than Skyrim or not
and why you can add the game spot we've
got stories on next month's games with
gold and potential V our support for no
man's sky that is everything I have for
you today let me know your thoughts and
feelings in that comment section and I
will catch you tomorrow